elon musk is the richest man in the
world he's also the ceo of tesla and
spacex he's trying to conquer mars and
do all sorts of other great things with
the boring company knurling but that's
not enough you're the richest guy in the
world you gotta find other stuff to keep
your attention elon has now this morning
gone ahead and put forward an offer to
buy twitter and of course in true elon
fashion how did he announce this well he
tweeted and he said i made an offer and
a link to an sec filing now elon musk of
course bought about 9.1 of twitter for 3
billion just a few weeks ago twitter
deciding what to do when the richest man
in the world wants to take a run at your
company they offered him a board seat it
looked like elon was going to take it at
the last minute the 11th hour elon
backed out and said i don't want to be
on your board and of course everyone
started to speculate is elon going to
make a hostile takeover attempt at
twitter well now we have our answer yes
elon musk he's going toe-to-toe let's
see what he can do so here is his offer
he went ahead and he said that he wants
to pay 54 and 20 cents per share it's a
54 premium over the closing price the
day before he actually took his position
and it's a 38 premium over the closing
price on april 1st and so if we go ahead
and we take a look what exactly is his
pitch well we've got this tweet here for
my brother joe it says twitter needs to
be transformed as a private company i
don't have confidence in management nor
believe i can drive the necessary change
in the public market and i'm not playing
the back and forth game my offer is best
and final this is the savagery that we
would expect from the world's richest
man as he goes for a hostile takeover
attempt if we then take a look at some
of the communication that had to be
public because twitter's a public
company it only gets better elon went
ahead and he sent a note to brett taylor
the chairman of the twitter board he
said that he invested in twitter because
he believes in the potential for free
speech around the globe and he believes
that free speech is societal imperative
for a functioning democracy but he now
realizes the company will neither thrive
nor serve this societal imperative in
its current form twitter needs to be
transformed as a private company as a
result he's offering to buy a hundred
percent of it for that fifty four
dollars and twenty cents per share his
offer is best and final and if not
accepted he would need to reconsider his
position as a shareholder twitter has
extraordinary potential and elon musk
believes he can unlock it but that's not
all we also have his text message here
where he texted and said as i indicated
this weekend i believe that the company
should be private to go through the
changes that need to be made after the
past several days of thinking this over
i have decided i want to acquire the
company and take it private i'm going to
send you an offer later tonight it will
be public in the morning are you
available to
chat sounds kind of like a you up text
and then lastly we can see that there's
a number of things that have been
outlined in some of the public documents
around this twitter acquisition you can
see here that he said this is his best
and final offer he's not playing the
back and forth game he has simply moved
straight to the end it's a high price
the twitter shareholders will love it
the deal doesn't work given that he
doesn't have confidence in management
and he doesn't believe that the public
market facilitates the necessary changes
he would need to reconsider his position
as a shareholder not a threat simply not
a good investment without the changes
that need to be made and those changes
won't happen without taking the company
private elon's advisors and his team
they're available to get you the letter
to answer any questions and there'll be
more detail in their public filings
that's exactly what i would expect from
the world's richest man this is
incredible to watch elon musk going ham
at twitter usually a lot of this types
of communications much more polished
done in a much more formal way elon's
just sitting there texting the chairman
of the twitter board it's filing things
publicly saying best and final let's go
straight to the end big dogs i got 43
billion dollars and i'm willing to spend
it to buy your company they offered him
a board seat he said no now he's gonna
try to buy the whole damn company this
is incredible and i gotta say this is
one of the most fun things to watch on
the internet right now i hope that elon
actually gets control of twitter it's
probably gonna be good for twitter it'll
probably be good for free speech i just
hope that elon doesn't get spread too
thin we still need elon to usher in
electric vehicles we need them to go
ahead and help settle mars and now elon
musk defender of free speech is just
another thing to add to his plate hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time